-Welcome back!
-Thank you.
I love how you always spotligh
amazing musicians.
-It's really nice.
Guest drummers.
It's such a delightful
to have them.
-Yeah, they're amazing. Yes.
-Each one is different.
They're like a snowflake
or a fingerprint.
-A snowflake.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
This is great.
Today it's official.
You have joined the family o
talk show hosts.
-Official.
-Your very own show.
-I watched it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You watched it?
It was on today.
I would like to toast you.
-Oh, yes.
-And I would like to welcome you
to the family.
We are so lucky to have you.
-Thank you.
Am I in a club with you?
-Yes, you are in the club now.
-Oh, my God.
-Take this away 'cause we know
what happens.
-Okay. We do.
[ Laughter ]
But it was fun.
-It was fun.
And you got to watch it today?
Was it exciting?
-I did. We watched --
It was a whole, like --
It was funny because people from
"The Voice," the talk show
my label, were all kind of
doing stuff at the same time
So we were all in my hotel roo
watching it.
-That's really exciting.
-It was. But then it's not
'cause, like, you're
watching yourself.
-Yeah, no, I agree.
-And, like, everyone's
watching with you.
-Yes.
-And it's the worst, yeah.
-I will say that I do not watc
this show with any regularity.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say that I probabl
won't watch it again.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Because it's, like, you.
I'm high-fiving you.
-Oh, great.
-It's like you. I'm like,
"You're leaving me hanging."
Let's do it again.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But it is -- I also think -
You know, one of the nice things
about doing these shows is
of course, the more you do them,
it's really great
to be in the moment of them.
-Yeah.
-And then to watch them
is only to see the things
that you wish
you had done differently.
-Yeah.
-And so there's no value
to that.
-I feel like I have enough
people telling me
what I should've done better
-I know when I got a show,
everybody asked me,
"Did you get invites
from other talk show hosts?"
Did you -- Did anybody tell yo
anything that was helpful?
-I mean, you were nice
and Jimmy and Ellen.
Everybody has been really nice
Everybody has just told me
to be me.
And I'm like, "Well, check."
[ Laughter ]
That's easy. Best advice ever.
I don't even have to work at it.
-Another question I get aske
all the time --
Do you have a dream guest?
-Meryl Streep.
-Meryl Streep. Right away.
-You. And then Meryl Streep.
-Thank you very much, yeah
[ Laughter ]
That was really --
[ Applause ]
-You and Meryl Streep.
-You are not Meryl Streep.
So I did not believe
that acting performance.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you not see
"From Justin to Kelly," Seth
-Justin stole that movie.
-My footprints are
right behind Meryl's.
-But do you think, like,
you could keep your composur
if you ever had her as a guest
-Yes.
-You do think you could?
-I do.
I was startled --
I know what everyone is thinking
because you might have see
the video of me freaking out
on the red carpet with her
But I was startled.
It wasn't -- It was unexpected
-I see, yeah.
-Yes.
-So you're saying like,
if you have enough warning
that you're gonna see
Meryl Streep, you'll be okay
-Yeah. I might have a drin
before the show.
[ Laughter ]
Just to calm down.
-Well, I'm sorry to surprise you
but look who's behind you.
-Yeah, alright.
No, don't do that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no.
-I'd be like,
"Ha, ha, it's fine."
It's fine.
I swear I'm not scary.
-You're also going to have
the "American Idol" judges
from your season
on the show as guests.
-Yeah, I think Justin
might be coming, too.
So that's exciting.
-Oh, that's exciting.
-Yeah, maybe a "From J to K 2.
-Yes.
-Everyone has been
dying for the sequel. I know it.
-The two things that people as
for is a new Avengers movi
and "Justin to Kelly 2."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm assuming you've seen the
all a lot over the years?
Have you --
-I run into --
Yeah, I've run into Simon
probably more than anyone.
But I hosted
the Billboard Awards last year
I kind of run into them
at random points.
-Does it bring you back --
Do you feel a nostalgia
for that time?
-Totally.
-And do you look back
at that time as --
Do you remember the stress
and anxiety of it more
or the success of it more?
-I remember the humor of i
'cause we were all very tired.
So we're all, like, you know
the hysterical point
where everything is funny?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. So there was
a lot of that 'cause we --
The show blew up
in that first season.
-Of course.
-Yeah, so we were pushed t
the nth degree.
Yeah, so I can handle anything
-That's good.
I want to ask about this
because I've heard rumors.
Is it true that your daughte
has already asked
when she is going to get to be
a guest on your show?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-And also she really
enjoys telling --
She just started kindergarten.
And people were talking abou
their parents.
She was like, "Oh, my parents --
My mom is Kelly Clarkson.
My dad's Brandon."
[ Laughter ]
Why?
I'm like, "I don't know
if you should say that.
You're going to hate in it
junior high probably." Yeah.
-And if she was
a guest on your show,
what do you think
she would want to do?
Like, how would she
present herself?
-I think I'm actually going to
see if she'll interview with me.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-That'd be really fun.
-Yeah, maybe I'll get her
to come when Meryl comes
and I'll feed the questions --
-Oh, that's really good.
-Yeah.
-Have a buffer around, yeah.
-Exactly, yes.
-So if it goes badly,
you can say to Meryl --
-Blame the 5-year-old.
-"This was not my fault."
-"This was her. She's horrible."
[ Laughter ]